[Musica]
are you were of your symbiotic
connection siete consapevoli della
vostra connessione simbiotica la prima
volta che ho sentito questa frase questa
domanda era il 22 aprile del 2019
il 22 aprile è la giornata mondiale dei
diritti di madre terra e da diversi anni
all'onu si tiene una conferenza su madre
terra e quell'anno il tema era
educazione e crisi climatica avevamo
passato il pomeriggio davanti al
computer guardando la diretta streaming
aspettando l'intervento di una donna di
medicina mori e rennes a ranghi marie e
rare o marchi rose una donna che abbiamo
avuto l'onore e il piacere di conoscere
con cui abbiamo lavorato e che abbiamo
anche accolto a casa nostra il suo il
suo intervento alle nazioni unite di
fronte a tutti i funzionari è iniziato
ponendo questa domanda io devo dire che
poi non mi ricordo neanche come
continuato il resto del dello speech
questa frase mi ha ha mi ha lasciato
così mia mi ha folgorato e ho continuato
a ripensarci anche se se conoscevo il
significato di tutte le singole parole
messe assieme non c'era qualcosa che non
mi tornava non riuscivo davvero a capire
quale fosse la mia connessione
simbiotica con con gli alberi col bosco
con gli animali con con l'ecosistema con
con il resto la parola simbiotica la
conoscevo ma gli esempi che mi venivano
in mente erano quegli esempi dal libro
di biologia ossia la simbiosi tra alcuni
insetti e alcuni alcuni alberi alcuni
impianti la simbiosi tra funghi e
batteri le radici degli alberi ma non
riuscivo a trovare la mia connessione
simbiotica e onestamente non riuscivo
neanche a trovarla in generale degli
esseri umani con il resto più o meno
nello stesso periodo avevamo ricevuto
una chiamata da un importante ente di
arte contemporanea che lavora sulle
dolomiti per partecipare ad una
collettiva d'arte con artistica e
avremmo avuto quindi l'occasione avevamo
già iniziato a frequentare i boschi del
cadore che da che da poco l'ottobre
precedente erano stati colpiti
attraversati dalla tempesta dalla
tempesta vaiano e mentre frequentavamo
quei boschi questa domanda c'era c'era
nella testa c'erano il cuore era molto
presente tant'è che in quell'occasione
che ne nata un'opera un'opera di altre
pubblica che porta a questo questo nome
questo titolo a rue aware of your
symbiotic connection dal bosco del
cadore al bosco dove noi viviamo e dal
2017 che abbiamo fondato un'azienda
agricola e ci siamo trasferiti a a
vivere qui in appennino qua vicino a 700
metri di altezza
l'azienda agricola per noi che appunto
siamo io sono un artista sembra ludovico
siamo un collettivo che siamo artisti
l'azienda agricola per noi un opera ci
siamo arrivati con il nostro col nostro
percorso di ricerca con con le nostre
azioni
abbiamo iniziato lavorando sul cibo con
il cibo sulla cultura alimentare quindi
a un certo punto per noi è diventato
indispensabile un'urgenza rimettere le
mani nella terra
l'azienda agricola un'opera perché è un
è un luogo è uno spazio di relazione per
noi ma anche per altre persone che noi
invitiamo con degli eventi collettivi a
relazionarsi con le piante che ci danno
da mangiare con gli animali che ci danno
da mangiare con tutto l'ecosistema la
pratica le pratiche e l'insieme di
pratiche che noi utilizziamo in
agricoltura sono quelle dell'agricoltura
organica e rigenerativa sostanzialmente
noi non coltiviamo le piante ma
coltiviamo
il suolo è un è un essere vivente
complesso di cui conosciamo ancora molto
poco composto da da tanti esseri diversi
e sostanzialmente ha bisogno di di cura
di essere comunque osservato di riavere
materia organica di riavere
microorganismi quindi sostanzialmente la
nostra cura della terra e delle piante
parte da da questo quindi quando ho
sentito per la prima volta questa
domanda è sostanzialmente vivevo vivevo
a contatto con la terra viveva contatto
con le piante ma comunque non mi era
chiaro mi era chiaro tutto quello che
loro davano a me che loro davano a noi
cibo nutrimento calore materiali per per
costruire per i nostri vestiti si
praticamente medicine tutto quello che
noi usiamo nella nostra vita quotidiana
ma il mio ruolo non era chiaro mi
rendevo conto che le piante così quelle
che noi coltivavamo quindi tutte specie
che sono state in qualche modo
selezionate nei secoli nei millenni per
stare con noi hanno bisogno di cure
quindi io me ne curavo ma uscendo da
questa relazione di cura non riuscivo
assolutamente a comprendere in che modo
con il selvatico con il bosco io potessi
avere questa connessione simbiotica
penso di avere iniziato questo percorso
di consapevolezza con l'opera l'opera
che nasce in cadore che porta questo
titolo
quest'opera è un'assemblea pubblica che
noi facciamo nel bosco sotto e intorno
agli alberi in questa assemblea noi li
invitiamo le persone che vivono un
determinato luogo quindi una comunità a
partecipare a questo momento un momento
di condivisione e di dialogo
invitiamo delle persone che possono
portare un'esperienza concreta di questa
connessione perché nelle loro vite già
presenti sono sempre presenti per
esempio
la mano oa donna di medicina maori e
silvia filosofa e curatrice di arte
contemporanea loro in qualche modo hanno
questo ruolo di rompere il ghiaccio e di
portare le persone con un dialogo attivo
più in profondità
in questo questo sentimento in questo
modo di vivere il rapporto con gli
alberi una natura il bosco gli animali
poi invitiamo anche altre persone e
queste sono persone che fanno parte
della comunità che ospita l'assemblea
sono forestali scienziati biologi
direttori di museo educatori sono figure
che vivono anche loro questo rapporto di
connessione e che facendo parte di
quella comunità o possono dare
concretezza e portare le persone più
vicino a questo modo di a questo modo di
vivere a questo modo di relazionarsi e
la cosa bellissima la cosa che io ho
imparato in questo in questo ciclo
perché adesso ormai ne abbiamo fatte 5
di assemblee sentiamo che è il momento
con urgenza di portare in giro questa
domanda è di cercare di fare un percorso
personale per ognuno in questo percorso
di consapevolezza e che non ci sono
ovviamente risposte univoche
anzi spesso ci sono molte più domande di
quante non siano delle risposte ma sono
delle posizioni personali meravigliose
poetiche che possono essere condivise e
che creano cambiamento effettivo nel
mondo per me è successo così io ho
iniziato da sempre di più ad andare nel
bosco non con un obiettivo specifico non
per raccogliere funghi o erbe non per
passeggiare non per fare del trekking ma
per stare
e questo stare nel bosco ha cambiato
molte cose della mia vita al di fuori
del bosco
credo che nella mia vita questo percorso
sia appena iniziato ed è una cosa che
continuerò continueremo a portare avanti
perché crediamo che sia davvero molto
importante nel ricollocare nel ricco
recarci nel rivedere il nostro ruolo
all'interno degli ecosistemi e su questo
pianeta è sostanzialmente un lavoro di
di apertura di dialogo e di
comunicazione con esseri che sono molto
diversi da noi ma che hanno come questi
alberi sono esseri vivi che pensano
intelligenti che sentono diversissimi da
noi difficilissimo entrare in contatto
con loro ma io credo fortemente che
qualcosa per andare in questa direzione
va dal fatto che potrebbe essere davvero
una chiave molto divertente e poetica
per trovare delle soluzioni davvero
innovative e sorprendenti davvero
sorprendenti
are you were of your symbiotic
connection siete consapevoli della
vostra relazione simbiotica andate nel
bosco chiedete il permesso prima di
entrare presentatevi manifestate le
vostre intenzioni anche a voce alta
trovato un posto un luogo che vi piace
cino un albero vicino a una roccia in
una radura e state ascoltate
ascoltatevi e sono sicura che qualcosa
succede qualcosa di molto bello
grazie
[Applauso]